ah ah
votre invité mathieu belliard et
sénateur de la vendée président du
groupe l'est républicain au sénat
bruno retailleau bonjour bruno
retailleau bonjour mathieu vélia j'ai
beaucoup de questions à vous poser
on va démarrer sur ces questions de
laïcité c'est affaire de voile et
d'accompagnatrice scolaire écoutons
ensemble le premier ministre à
l'assemblée hier
je ne pense pas que l'enjeu aujourd'hui
ce soit de faire une loi sur les
accompagnants scolaires
l'enjeu c'est de combattre efficacement
les dérives communautaires vous du côté
de la droite au sénat
vous allez déposer vous avez déposé une
proposition de loi qui sera débattue à
la fin du mois d'octobre justement pour
élargir cette interdiction du port du
voile aux mamans accompagnatrices colère
y compris en dehors des établissements
vous tendez un piège à la majorité pas
du tout mais tu es liart nous avons
déposé un texte il ya bientôt deux
années et nous avons déjà voté un
amendement d'ailleurs sur le port du
voile dans les sorties scolaires
au moment du vote de la loi pour la
confiance non je pense que le chef du
gouvernement et plus il anime il parle
il parle fort mais il n'agit pas et
aujourd'hui on doit agir j'écoutais tout
à l'heure dans le journal de 7 heures ce
reportage dans dans l'oise vous savez qu
à creil
c'est en 1989 qu'a commencé le problème
sur les élèves les collégiennes qui
était voilée et il a fallu attendre 15
ans en 2004 pour que la représentation
nationale vote une loi et avant cela
nous avons laissé se débrouiller les
enseignants les directeurs
d'établissement bel et là on en est au
même point
quand jean michel blanquer redit le
voile n'est pas souhaitable dans notre
société
avec cette proposition de loi que vous
déposez voulu dit en gros si vous êtes
cohérent vous votez notre texte
bien sûr ce que je veux vous dire c'est
que je ne veux pas interdire le voile
dans la rue dans l'espace public en
général
notre texte est destiné simplement
sorties scolaires pourquoi parce qu'il
faut protéger l'école l'école doit être
un sanctuaire débarrasser d'abord des
querelles des hommes débarrasser aussi
des signes ostentatoires vous savez il
ya quelques mois simplement c'est une
décision qui a échappé à tout le monde à
tous les observateurs en juillet dernier
le 23 juillet la cour administrative
d'appel de lyon a pris une décision
importante elle a donné raison
un directeur d'école qui voulait imposer
la neutralité à des parents d'élèves qui
venaient en classe dans les activités
scolaires
alors pour moi comme pour tous
d'ailleurs les sorties scolaires
c'est la classe c'est l'école hors les
murs hors les murs c'est une
prolongation des activités scolaires
donc il faut protéger les enfants parce
que ce sont des consciences en formation
il faut les débarrasser de ce qui peut
être des signes ostentatoires politique
ou religieux bruno retailleau je
voudrais que l'on parle de la situation
géopolitique extrêmement complexe le
kurdistan syrien vous êtes engagés sur
ce dossier sauvons nos alliés kurde vous
étiez à ce rassemblement il y reçoit
trans partisan d'ailleurs puisqu'on
retrouvait des républicains comme vous
des udi qui ont lancé l'organisation de
ce rassemblement mais aussi des maires
des insoumis la maire de paris il ya la
crainte d'une résurgence de dèche sur le
terrain vous vous demandez à la france
de rappeler son ambassadeur en turquie
ça fait peur à qui bruno retailleau vous
avez évidemment que lorsque monsieur
erdogan prend des armes
c'est sans doute par des hommes qui
voudraient lui résister mais moi je ne
veux pas ajouter la guerre à la guerre
il faut utiliser les moyens
diplomatiques notamment que nous avons à
disposition on est en train par cette
funeste décision de monsieur trump on
est en train de lâcher les kurdes les
kurdes se sont eux qui ont fait le sale
boulot 7e qui ont accueilli j étais moi
en doute 2014 à erbil dans le kurdistan
irakien
ils ont accueilli les yézidis les
chrétiens les chabat toutes les
minorités persécutées par dash les thaïs
la vie c'est eux qui ont résisté avec
les femmes combattants d antigone d
antigone de la liberté voilà dix
antigone en même temps qui se dressaient
contre le mais vous avez parlé des armes
bruno retailleau faut s'attendre à
devoir intervenir sur le terrain non je
pense que j'ai formulé d'autres
propositions je pense que eux nous
serions bien inspirés de prendre des
sanctions économiques
quand monsieur poutine en veille la
crimée on lui rétorque par des sanctions
économiques pourquoi ne le fait-on pas
avec la turquie
deuxième proposition il faudrait
décréter une zone d'exclusion aérienne
au-dessus du nord du nord-est de la
syrie pour que les combattants kurdes
puisse être à même niveau d'égalité si
j'ose dire face à l'envahisseur
peut-être que si on ne fait pas si on ne
prend pas ces sanctions économiques
c'est qu'on a une certaine crainte
recep tayyip erdogan a annoncé qu'il
pourrait ouvrir les barrières pour faire
simple
ces deux de laisser passer plus de trois
millions et demi de réfugiés ya un
chantage qui est fait par rapport à
l'espace schengen est ce que est ce
qu'on va devoir justement le restreindre
pendant un temps est ce qu'il faut aller
au clash avec erdogan
mais l'histoire montre qu' on ne peut
pas transiger sur le sondage sur un
chantage sinon on a non seulement le
déshonneur on a aussi la guerre comme
disait quelqu'un en d'autres temps je
pense qu'il faut être très ferme avec la
turquie d'erdogan
tout simplement parce qu'il ne comprend
que le rapport de force et nous sommes
en train encore une fois d'abandonner
les kurdes ça n'est pas seulement pour
les kurdes qu'on doit le faire c'est
aussi pour nous tout simplement parce
que cette action est en train de
favoriser la résurgence de l'état
islamique
tous les observateurs le disent tous les
observateurs le voient et ensuite il ya
la dispersion des jihadistes français
qui sont enfermés dans des camps qui
sont gardés justement par des perches
mais rigueur par les cures de
combattants qui vont justement justement
ce matin ce sera à la une du journal de
8 heures vous serez à l'ecoute je
l'espère bruno retailleau europe 1
dévoile le plan que tente de mettre en
place le gouvernement pour gérer
justement cette question des djihadistes
éviter qu'il ne s'évaporent dans la
nature
je vous pose une question très simple
très clair très courte il faut qu'il
soit rapatrié en france jugé emprisonné
ici ou est-ce qu'il faut qu'on les
envoie vers d'autres alliés peut-être
l'irak
il faut les envoyer vers l'irak c'est ma
position constante je suis allé à
plusieurs reprises en irak et j'ai reçu
les témoignages des exactions de l'état
islamique
quand un crime et cogner sur une terre
c'est sur cette terre là qu'il faut
évidemment jugé le crime c'est ce que
demandent les victimes
alors il faut transférer précisément les
djihadistes les plus dangereux des
geôles justement kurdes en irak
merci bruno retailleau
[Musique]
ah ah